now something that I really need to say
before we start watching the armored
Core 6 fires of Rubicon gameplay trip
and not in a hipster way okay
I have loved armored Core for such a
long time for so long you could go back
and find clips of me from 10 years ago
talking about how much I love ahmadkor
it's just me being like woo Ahmed core
let's go I love big robot game for a
really long time I think the clip on
kind of funny they asked me how I felt
about armid core and they had asked
people that question repeatedly and I
was the only person to ever have played
it here is a very hard hitting question
from uh more
sand
does Alana think armored Core can be
revitalized with a new gameplay mechanic
I think almond Cole can be revitalized
anyway
like I really like those games we
haven't had a Mech game
oh my God it's been 118 episodes and
it's finally happened have a guest on
the show that has played armored Core
and now this trailer for almond cool has
1.4 million views basically
I'm like so happy about this because
from my perspective fromsoft makes a
game that everybody loves in Elden room
it's their most mainstream game yet some
like hotcakes reviews are phenomenal
everybody loves it and instead of
following up with Elden Ring 2 the first
thing we get immediately afterwards is
armored Core look at all these new
armored Core fans that we're gonna have
We're not gonna have to wait this long
until they make another armored Core
ever again I'm just so happy this is
happening it's a funny one though
because like when I was playing armored
Core back in the day I will admit that I
didn't play
um verdict day which is on me uh which
is their last release I think it was
like 20. I'm still in Australia this is
2014 2013 probably but Ahmed Core 5
Ahmed core 4 I was all over them and I
expect this game to be a bit more like
almond core 3 which for anyone who
doesn't know it was like a reboot of the
franchise that came out in 2004
baby baby I'm gonna google it 2002.
I was bearish in any case I'm super
excited and I've almost never felt this
way about anything there are certainly
many games that I have loved that other
people don't give a [__] about and then
I will shout for the rooftops that
everybody should play this one though is
in such a unique position to be so
successful that I want this this
Gameplay trailer which is what this is
we're actually seeing gameplay to be
good so badly because I want armored
Core to just stay forever now I'm just
very excited about this in a way that
I'm not normally excited about trailers
I'm not excited for me to see armored
Core 6 I mean I am but it's that and I'm
okay I need to stop let's watch the
trailer dude I got chills seeing this at
the game awards in person it was
beautiful
Handler Walter verified
activating cerebral Coral control device
[Music]
oh my God
the density
this is such a
it's so dramatic I was expecting to just
just be gameplay
has awakened
yo let's go
I'm just so happy to be here man
[Applause]
I mean it looks a lot like almond Cole
thank you
big tank boy look at him go
you know you can't drift on treads
they always do it though
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
interesting
you ready to climb the wall
dude this is a really good trailer
I have things to say that I'm not saying
we'll do a second watch through so that
I can talk about some of the stuff I'm
seeing
outside
[Music]
let's see how far they can fly
borrowed wings
oh my God that's such a good trailer
dude
okay
I don't pre-order games I don't pre-ord
games [__]
I do want that though
August 25th it comes out the day after
my birthday let's go okay
um some things I saw in this trailer
that we want to break down here so the
biggest thing that like kept blowing me
away here that like I think is cool
regardless but maybe some other armored
Core fans wouldn't know is that the
environments are like infinitely more
detailed than they were
in any previous armored Core game which
of course makes sense the environments
were pretty lackluster this is a huge
step forward and I will say
um the previous I would call games were
a little bit janky like I think most
Mech games have been uh clearly I still
love them anyway and it always made
sense to me that they didn't take off
like Dark Souls which feels very very
refined bloodborne even more so Elder
and even more so right this looks like a
huge Improvement and I can't get it out
of my head that I think it maybe it'll
pave the way for more Mech games maybe a
triple A version of a Gundam game where
previously we're getting sort of smaller
productions for Gundam games maybe maybe
even Titanfall 3 maybe even Titanfall 3.
there are also a big difference it seems
less grounded than previous almond cool
games like the scale seems a lot bigger
I felt that way from the previous
trailer as well they are actually pretty
grounded games this seems like it's
going for a much bigger scale like
literally it looks like the vertical
boost jump is way way way higher
um I'm really interested to see if that
maybe that's tied to your literal like
jumping stat they could do some really
cool stuff with boosting there I also
feel like in a way that probably is very
souls and for reference these games are
not that sozy they're hard but they're
not like that soulsy in DNA and this
does look slightly more soulsy but this
isn't just Mech Dark Souls to be clear
for anyone who doesn't know that's not
what Ahmed koi is but I wonder if
because it looks like the verticality or
like the the jumping height is way
higher if we're gonna get way bigger
bosses too because that is
super exciting also these energy blades
oh my God the coolest thing I've ever
seen that's so so cool I'm gonna need to
watch this again maybe like a thousand
times
um but I will spare you all of that
I'm Alana I'm very excited uh thank you
guys for watching I will see y'all next
time bye